Before we start to use the clothing tool itself I'd like to quickly go over some of the tools
features and what the tool looks like so that we have a better idea of its functionality once
we start to use it in the editor. So first off when we open up the tool at the top we're
going to have our clothing data. Now this is going to be where all of the meshes that we
want to have some type of clothing effect are added. When we select one of them underneath
that we're going to have masks and our masks can do actually a lot of different things. We have one
called max distance which is the maximum distance any point on the cloth can move from its animated
position and this is going to be the most common property that you need for your cloth to be
interactive throughout the world. There is backstop distance, backstop radius, anim drive
stiffness, anim drive dampening, tether stiffness, tether scale, drag lift, edge stiffness, bending
stiffness, area stiffness, buckling stiffness, and pressure. All of these have a slightly different
and yet useful effect on the way the cloth is going to react to things around it in the world.
However one setting isn't necessarily going to fix cloth or make something happen or make
something not happen. It's going to be a collection of different settings and there's going to be
no one magic bullet but the best thing about this tool is it is very easy to add multiple masks
and adjust their settings so that we can test things out very quickly without having to worry
about going back to our dcc or anything like that. So if you are having something maybe you
need to add a little lift or a little drag but you're not sure how much you can always paint
that in and it's very easy to add that data and delete that data. Next we have under our config
we have our chaos clothing config and our chaos clothing shared simulation config. So the top
basically is the settings for our simulation on this piece of cloth and the bottom are settings
for how cloth is going to react as a whole throughout our entire project. So we're going
to mainly focus on the top sections. The bottom section is a little bit more advanced and be
careful adjusting it because it will have a effect on a cloth throughout your entire project. So
let's look at the top and what it is broken down into. So we have first off our mass properties
this controls the mass or the density of the cloth material so if we increase this number
we're going to make it more dense if we decrease it we're going to make it lighter so think
a very heavy cloth or leather might have a value that is closer to one while something like
silk or maybe a little oily or something like that might have a value of 0.0001.
Also for these particular values no matter what value you are entering here
smaller values are always better so multiple decimal points it's going to give you a much
better result so instead of using 0.1 try 0.1256. Underneath that we have our material
properties no I already went over that no material properties adjust the stiffness of the cloth
material so there we go we have our edge stiffness our bending stiffness using bending
elements and our area stiffness now again the great thing about this is I can adjust these
and see it real time happening in the editor so there is nothing necessarily set that cloth needs
to apply to these one doesn't necessarily mean anything other than full zero means completely
off so you have that entire decimal range to work with long range attachment deals with
how the solver reacts when iteration count is low and it's used to help prevent stretching
our collision properties adjust how the cloth will collide with itself and our
animation properties can controls how animation either affects the cloth or reacts to the cloths
animation our environment properties control how the cloth simulation reacts with things in the
environment and then our simulation the last one that increases the number of steps increasing
the resolution making the cloth react more lifelike however doing that will take more
resources so by adjusting that we are actually going to make this less performant now one of
the other cool things that we can do with our cloth and the other masks that we talked about
in the beginning is we have the ability to paint them using different tools we have a gradient
a brush a smooth and a fill you can also bring in and use gradients or fills that you've created
inside of a digital content creation program and stored in the red green or blue vertex color so
that's right you can use vertex color information that's already been created if you are say making
a cape and you know exactly where you want the cloth to be and you've already set that up and
painted it in your dcc you can bring that over and set that up but if not you can do it inside of
unreal now our brush is going to allow us to just paint all of the vertices at a given value
so this is really good if we know that the entire thing needs to be cloth or there's going
to be a large area that's cloth or we want to just specify a little bit of an area to paint
we can do that our gradient gives us the ability to have a gradient so we can do a gradient
between cloth and no cloth or active cloth and semi-active cloth and then have values assigned
that go from say 0 to 1 or 0 to 100 depending on the value that we want for it its effect and
the gradient will apply a gradient value starting at 0 and then as it goes along the
cloth it'll do a value 1 2 so on and so on until it reaches whatever our ending value is and
this gives us some really great cloth reaction and you'll see we're going to actually use
gradient for our example here smooth allows us to smooth the area out so let's say that we
are painting something and we notice that the edges or the transition is harsh we can use
the smoothing tool to actually smooth that transition out allowing us to have a better
transition between areas that either have cloth or don't have cloth or areas that go between
a very very flexible cloth maybe not so flexible cloth last but not least we have the fill
and this allows us to quickly fill an entire area of cloth this is really good if you have maybe say
multiple cloth panels on something and you need to just quickly make sure that they all have a
certain cloth setting you can go in there and just click on them with the fill tool fill them
all in you don't have to worry about painting or adding a gradient so with that done this is
going to wrap up our chaos clothing workflows and tool overview and the next part of this
tutorial we are going to get started with our chaos clothing exercise so make sure you have
unreal engine 5 started and ready to go and i'll see you in just a bit